let's find out what's happening right
now with lawmakers and these bills to
reopen the government chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
is on Capitol Hill tonight could even
Mike record evening once there's
agreement things move very quickly here
on Capitol Hill this bill has cleared
the Senate should pass the House very
soon and then be sent up to the
President to sign to get furloughed feds
back to work we're grateful to Democrats
on both sides of the Capitol for their
unity a victory lap for the top
Democrats for holding the line on the
partial shutdown with government
reopening in a hurry the hope is the
State of the Union address will be
rescheduled soon so if you mean is not
planned the Senate majority leader is
warning Democrats must be serious or
else the only way the federal workers
are going to have stability and
certainty beyond the next three weeks
the only way our border is going to have
real security is if Democrats will stop
playing partisan games and get serious
about negotiating with the president on
a long-term compromise and supporters of
the president are praising him for being
the grown-up in the room what is
happening here today is that the
president put the American public first
that the president said let's go pay the
federal employees and let's get into a
meeting room because we've tried to meet
with the speaker and and Schumer and
they will not negotiate on anything
North Carolina Republican congressman
Mark meadows saying if negotiations
don't result in a solution executive
action is still very much under
consideration but the Democrat chairman
of the Homeland Security Committee
Bennie Thompson says Democrats remain
committed to effective border security
but will only allow taxpayer money be
spent on border security measures that
will actually make a difference
lawmakers were clearly feeling the
pressure hearing about the impact of the
partial shutdown from constituents and
seeking a way out
the real ramifications of a shutdown er
are starting to be the scene that's not
simply an aggregating effect I think
you'll see a cascading effect a homeland
security spokeswoman says back pay
should start flowing to employees there
within two to three business days so by
mid next week payroll issues vary by
agency so the advice to employees is to
check with your bosses Brett Mike
Emanuel live on the hill Mike thanks